ten c'est le dossier de ce journal
une surprise la deuxième étape du tour
de france qui conduisait les coureurs de
barcarès à font romeu le maillot jaune a
changé des pôles il était porté par le
belge van impe mais aujourd'hui le
français raymond delisle a nettement
gagné cette première étape dans les
pyrénées après une échappée de 75 km
raymond delisle est arrivé détaché à
font romeu précédent de 4 minutes 59
secondes l'espagnol menendez de cinq
minutes et 4 secondes et l'italien pizza
et de près de sept minutes le peloton
avec les principaux leaders
cette étape n'était pas véritablement
une étape de haute montagne sur ce
terrain accidenté qui me convenait fort
bien mais monde les trente trois ans est
parvenu à maintenir une avance
suffisamment consistante pour endosser
pour la première fois de sa carrière le
maillot jaune ce soir au classement
général de lille près cette grogne de
deux minutes quarante et une secondes
doute mail de deux minutes 47 secondes
raymond poulidor de 4 minutes 17
secondes et bernard thévenet de quatre
minutes 53 secondes
bonsoir enfin un répit la canicule
aujourd'hui à reculer et tous nous
sommes sentis revivre il semble que la
chaleur s'éloigne pour de beaux orage ou
petite pluie sur certaines régions est
ce que cela sera suffisant pour remédier
à la sécheresse
pour certaines cultures comme le maïs et
les pommes de terre il est déjà trop
tard
monsieur saglio monsieur sécheresse ce
matin n'était pas optimiste pour lui les
pluies passagères ne peuvent mettre un
terme à la sécheresse
alors eh bien alors quels remèdes pour
la pluie
prié pour la pluie peut-être la
fabriquer et bien la science s'en occupe
mais les faiseurs de pluie c'est encore
bien sûr du domaine de la recherche
peut-on faire pleuvoir en laboratoire
apparemment oui c'est possible à
phalsbourg le prouve avec cette machine
le principe en est simple un espace clos
une différence de température entre deux
plaques et regardez bien ça va marcher
ça commence à venir
voilà comment ce
comment ça peut voir
ou alors ceux ci vis et de la pluie dans
un espace très klaus mais c'est pas
vraiment de la pluie c'est des petites
boules initiation ce sont des
gouttelettes qui sent tout à fait
analogue aux bouteilles de pluie
évidemment ça se passe dans une enceinte
fermée et très petit par rapport à
l'atmosphère mais en face se sont
réellement des gouttes d'eau tel quel ce
et se forme dans l'atmosphère que les
gens souhaitent ceux qui pleurent est-ce
que vos travaux peuvent aider à
éventuellement trouver des solutions
pour précipiter plus oui enfin nous
sommes dans des conditions qui est je
vais elle dit sont assez loin quand même
des conditions atmosphériques nous
sommes dans une atmosphère dans cette
chambre qui est très très pure mais a il
ne fait aucun doute que la compréhension
des phénomènes
d'abord simple à pourra aider ensuite à
comprendre les phénomènes plus compliqué
la météo est intéressé à vos travaux
c'est la météorologie nationale qui
finance ce travail il ne s'agit que
d'une expérience si on ne sait pas
encore si tout cela est très sérieux
comment peut se demander si ce qui fonde
la météo à très long terme le sont
beaucoup plus en tout cas celui que vous
allez entendre avait bien prévu la
sécheresse un an auparavant
il n'est guère optimiste il y aura des
orages comme il y en a eu peut-être des
petites pointes de pluie il me fait rien
de sérieux avant septembre
c'est alors la raison profonde jolie
niort je ne suis pas devin je me borne à
constater ce qu'à travers une méthode
nous avons vu alors quelle est votre
méthode ou c'est très simple ça consiste
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure à
déterminer une situation astronomes et
rick astro métriques plus exactement
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelait autrefois
d'assaut les positions pour un jour
déterminé dans l'avenir et ensuite une
fois que cela est fait rechercher dans
un passé connu sur le plan
météorologique
une situation identique tout le monde la
plus proche si vous travaillez par
analogie exactement quand vous avez
découvert cette sécheresse quel effet ça
vous a fait vous avez pensé dit avec lui
non j'ai eu peur et c'est pour ça que je
refais tous mes calculs en sens inverse
et puis après considérons à 3
que savez une certaine fleurs j'ai tenu
et mes amis aussi
on a tenu à prévenir les ans les
pouvoirs publics d'une part et puis
d'autre part aussi nous avons des
clients mais personne vous allez goûter
si parce que notre clientèle nous comme
on de clientèle nous paye bord cette
information aux quelque chose est une
peule clients avec une petite clientèle
nous sommes des artisans enfin nous
vivons de cela modestement
rassurez-nous une sécheresse comme ça on
en verra plus on va voir encore une
année exceptionnelle pas donner sens à
celle ci je ne vous dis pas pour
l'instant comme elle sera mais elle sera
normal les plus values au sénat voilà
qu'au moment où l'on commencé à
comprendre ce qu'elle représentait les
sénateurs décident de débaptiser le
projet de loi et adopte une nouvelle
terminologie l'imposition de certains
bénéfices ils débattent en s'ingéniant à
coups d'amendements à rendre le projet
le moins douloureux possible pour les
contribuables les présidents des deux
assemblées ont interrompu en fin d'après
midi les débats pour réciter leur
discours de fin de session bizarre car
députés et sénateurs pourraient bien se
croire autorisé à partir en vacances
avant de terminer leur copie plus value
ou bénéfices quelles sont les
modifications apportées au texte par le
sénat le sénat mettra cette nuit le
point final à son minutieuse épluchage
de la taxation des plus-values ce
difficile exercice s'est poursuivie à un
bon rythme dans le but avoué leur
assurer trois contribuables sur quatre
sans faire aucun procès politique au
gouvernement du moins dans leur majorité
les sénateurs ont mis en pièce une bonne
partie des douze articles du projet
monsieur fourcade malgré toute son
énergie a été battu sur bien des points
jugés par lui important c'est ainsi que
le patrimoine familial ne serait plus
taxés qu'au delà de 500 mille francs
les seuils d'exonération et les
abattements ont été relevées pour les
ventes de meubles et d'image est le
terme le plus value a été remplacé par
celui de bénéfices la nuance et la
subtile et presque psychologique
le contribuable calcule qu'il a fait une
plus value sur son bien sans pour autant
le vendre tandisque bénéfices nous
semble une notion plus dynamique
c'est-à-dire qu'il réalisa bénéfices au
moment de la vente
moi je pense que la publicité qui a été
fait autour du mot plus à lui sans doute
engage le ministre a tenté de garder
jusqu'au bout
ce mot qu'il avait choisi sans doute
avec le président la république enfin
c'est son problème
la consommation est une affaire de
professionnels au niveau de la vente
on s'en était aperçu mais pour madame
scrivener il faut que chaque
consommateur devienne un acheteur
professionnel
le secrétaire d'état à la consommation
qui était à rungis ce matin a retenu une
idée qui pourrait être expérimentée dès
l'automne à l'occasion d'une vaste
concertation qui réunira tous ceux de la
distribution
l'idée est bien plus qu à rungis on
connaît les prix de gros le soir il est
possible d'orienter immédiatement le
consommateur sur ses achats du lendemain
il sera informé a priori et non plus a
posteriori on pourrait croire que cette
nouvelle race qu'on appelle avec de plus
en plus de respect le consommateur a
gagné à force de se défendre
chouchoutez depuis peu par les pouvoirs
publics les associations de
consommateurs ne sont elles pas au
contraire en train de se laisser
récupérer en premier lieu par les
magasins à grande surface qui flairant
le vent ont continué leurs apps la
séduire les consommateurs la publicité a
même inventé un véritable langage pour
vanter les mérites de telle ou telle
marque
mais ces qualités sont de plus en plus
contestée aujourd'hui pour vendre
certains n'hésitent plus à employer le
vocabulaire de la politique un coup
d'audace
il ya aussi une vaste opération de
marketing car en supprimant le nom de la
marque les slogans et les emballages
coûteux on la tire les ménagères et on
coupe l'herbe sous le pied des critiques
si vous ne le faites pas ce que je
demande les associations de
consommateurs
vous êtes un sales capitalistes et si
vous le faites
vous êtes un hypocrite et des
récupérateurs alors moi je préfère faire
ce que jean-louis j'ai envie de faire ce
qui est bon pour l'intérêt des
consommateurs et ignorer ces jugements
dip aux cris de capitalistes de
récupérateurs un banc d'essai qui ne
coûte pas cher d'autres distributeurs
vont même plus loin et offre des espaces
publicitaires dans les journaux aux
organisations de consommateurs unique
préoccupation obtenir leur neutralité
comme depuis dix ans le mouvement des
consommateurs ne cessent de se
développer
les chefs d'entreprise sont bien obligés
d'en tenir compte aussi pour s'adapter
aux exigences nouvelles du marché
il s'entoure de spécialistes mais
monsieur consommateurs at il un
véritable pouvoir face au directeur du
marketing
prenons un cas précis par exemple le
mois dernier il ya eu 5 réclamations
l'association de consommateurs bon le
premier cas concerne une contestation de
qualité du matériel il s'agissait d'une
machine à coudre livre est incomplète et
qui ne marchait pas mal gré de réglage
en atelier loi présente avec essayé de
revendre une autre machine plus cher
prétexte au referee immédiatement
monsieur consommateur est intervenue a
demandé au directeur régional de faire
livrer une machine à coudre 9 en
reprenant la machine à coudre incriminés
et c'est ce qui a été fait quelles que
soient les pouvoirs que peut avoir ou
que pourrait avoir un monsieur
consommation dans une grande entreprise
il ne pourra jamais se substituer de
toute façon au rôle que doivent jouer
sur un plan global militants dans la
politique de la consommation les
mouvements représentatifs et sur le plan
de la formation de l'éducation la
protection techniques économiques et
juridiques du consommateur le rôle que
doit jouer selon les termes mêmes de l
esprit de la loi et du décret qui ont
constitué l'institut de la consommation
votre organisme
alors réalité ou illusion récupération
ou pas une chose est sûre c'est que tout
le monde se lance dans la bataille
au nom de la défense des consommateurs
même les syndicats viennent de rentrer
dans le débat
pourquoi pas demain les partis
politiques clientèle oblige le père a on
pensait que tout allait s'arranger ce
soir entre les syndicats la direction et
bien pas du tout c'est le contraire qui
s'est produit
le corps de ballet maintient son préavis
de grève
pour ce soir une grande partie du
personnel a répondu non aux propositions
de la direction
ce n'est pas encore la fermeture mais
c'est un pas de plus vers le non retour
tous ceux qui aiment l'art lyrique tous
ceux qui sont fiers de voir l'opéra de
paris re devenue la première scène du
monde ne savait plus s'il fallait
s'inquiéter ou espérait pourtant en à
temps pour la saison prochaine un
programme fabule on se demandait si on
pourrait voir ou non la flûte enchantée
la walkyrie et tout ce que rolf
liebermann a prévu car depuis le mois de
mai rappelons le il ya cette menace
précise de jacques chirac
attention c'est l'état qui tient à bout
de bras le financement de l'opéra
attention les 12 milliards ancien du
budget sont gaspillées dans des frais de
personnel excessif attention si le
personnel n'y met pas du sien
on ne paiera plus et ce sera la
liquidation alors coincé entre le
chômage et la négociation les syndicats
de l'opéra ont négocié et ce soir ils
ont donné leur réponse
la réponse est non alors le corps de
ballet s'est prononcé sur les conditions
de travail
le refus est catégorique pratiquement à
l'unanimité nous allons à 6h30
partir pour matignon pour expliquer au
premier ministre pourquoi nous refusons
les conditions de travail
le ballet a raison de se battre il est
soutenu par tout le personnel parce
c'est son existence est en jeu mais
aujourd'hui on vient de consulter le
personnel sur l'ensemble des
propositions qui était présenté pour les
deux tiers c'est non le corps de ballet
dit non les syndicats ils nous ont
transmis le nom des deux tiers du
personnel
qu'est ce que vous allez faire mais
d'abord je m'inscris en faux contre
cette analyse il y a dans le personnel
de l'opéra quatre groupes
le groupe du syndicat cftc le vote du
syndicat cfdt le moule du syndicat cgt
et le groupe des agents non sa nuque
on se dirige vers ce qui peut être un
drame mais après une décision qui doit
être celle que je vais vous dire
le problème est celui de l'existence de
l'opéra sur ce problème c'est le
gouvernement qui doit décider dans ce
problème il y à un élément essentiel qui
est le personnel sur l'existence de
l'opéra il faut connaître la position du
personnel de l'opéra la position du
personnel de l'opéra ce n'est pas un
syndicat c'est l'ensemble du personnel
de l'opéra constitué par trois syndicats
plus le groupe des non syndiqués jeu
réunit donc demain à 14h30 le personnel
de l'opéra tout syndicat et non
syndiqués réunis pour le faire va t sur
le projet du gouvernement
si ce projet est rejeté naturellement la
solution qui va s'imposer gouvernement
sera la solution de la fermeture de la
perte
edmond simeoni devant la cour de sûreté
de l'état aujourd'hui cette fois c'est
pour témoigner en faveur de serge
cacciari accusé d'avoir tué un crs lors
des nuits chaudes de la corse
le 27 août dernier pour le chef de file
des autonomistes cacciari n'est pas
abandonné il ne doit pas servir de bouc
émissaire car des dizaines de militants
corses le soutiennent edmond simeoni a
expliqué aussi que l'état continue sa
politique de l'autruche encore aucun
signe d'amélioration divisible d'autres
événements grains se produiront dans peu
de temps
la sphère des boues rouges la société
montedison vient d'être acquitté par un
tribunal italien la montedison s'est
rendu célèbre il ya quatre ans par ses
usines et ses bateaux qui déversait des
déchets flottants en méditerranée les
fameuses boues rouges sur plainte des
pêcheurs corse et italiens une suite de
procès a eu lieu avec même une
condamnation de la société mais depuis
une loi italienne a été votée elle
décide qu'il ya prescription pour ce
genre de délit
en conséquence la montedison a été
acquitté reste à savoir maintenant
quelles seront la réaction des pêcheurs
corse
obsèques nationales pour l'ancien
président allemand gustav heinemann
annoncé aujourd'hui son successeur pas
le torch el boustane heinemann décédé
hier à l'âge de 77 ans asn avait été
président de 1969 à 1974
les allemands garderont sans doute de
leur ancien président l'image d'un homme
simple honnête pacifique et surtout anti
conformiste
plusieurs fois ministre avant d'être élu
chef de l'état y va toujours faire il a
toujours préféré faire passer ses
convictions avant la raison d'état et
l'exercice du pouvoir
voulez-vous danser avec moi majesté
pourquoi pas président ainsi hier soir à
la maison blanche dans les jardins de la
maison blanche la reine elizabeth et le
président ford sont entrés dans cette
danse diplomatique
la reine elizabeth et le prince philip
sont en visite officielle aux états unis
en ce moment dans le cadre des fêtes du
bicentenaire hier soir en l'honneur du
couple royal gerald ford et son épouse
ont offert un dîner de 2 140 couverts et
puis à la fin du dîner
un bal fut donnée et ma foi la reine et
le président ont fort bien danser
le nouveau gouvernement espagnol a prêté
serment aujourd'hui à midi au palais de
la zarzuela le pré le président monsieur
adolfo suarez vient de passer quatre
jours bien difficile les trois ministres
réformiste de l'ancien gouvernement
navarro qui avait décliné et toute
mission ne voulant pas cautionner leur
libéralisme
la nouvelle équipe ces trois ministres
ces trois ministres ont tenté jusqu'au
dernier moment de convaincre le roi de
changer de chef de gouvernement et ce
n'est que tard la nuit dernière que
monsieur suarez a réussi à former son
cabinet composé en grande partie de
ministre inconnu du grand public
ce gouvernement que chacun désigne comme
transitoire l arrivée mercredi le match
de mardi nora berra ministre des
affaires étrangères à 41 ans entré avec
ses amis de sa speedo qui donne à ce
gouvernement la pinte de libéralisme et
d'ouverture que tout le monde fera
cordes soudainement aujourd'hui à lui
renault tout al'air monsieur raoul
murdoch le socialiste le plus proche des
communistes a déclaré qu'il était prêt à
entamer le dialogue avec les nouveaux
dirigeants et communistes ont jusqu'à
présent été les moins critiques de toute
opposition
peut-être ont-ils décidé avant les
autres d'accorder le bénéfice du doute à
la nouvelle équipe
s'il s'agit d'un groupe de jeunes
démocrates chrétiens de droite 45 ans
d'âge en moyenne
la nouvelle équipe est composée de
cadres brillant une action qu'est ce que
les bourgeoises ambitieux mais réaliste
donc libéraux dans le contexte pagnol à
qu ils veulent avant tout que l'espagne
rejoint le plus vite et le plus
complètement possible
le groupe des nations occidentales et
pour cela selon il n'y a qu'une voie
l'instauration d'une démocratie réelle
pas encore de point final à la faire
dans tv tout d'abord c'est demain que le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu examinera
la plainte déposée par les pays
africains contre israël et puis parce
qu'un otage a disparu il s'agit d'une
vieille dame anglaise qui avant le raid
israélien avait été transporté à
l'hôpital de kampala un sondage ifop
réalisé pour notre confrère le progrès
de lyon indique que 71 % des français
approuvent l'opération d'israël en
ouganda
eh bien ce n'est pas l'opinion des
pilotes de ligne français le syndicat
national des pilotes de ligne vient de
condamner le principe de l'intervention
armée en tas de détournement d'avion
d'un coup de théâtre dans le tour de
france raymond delisle est arrivé tout
seul à font romeu
le coureur français qui n'est plus tout
jeune 33 ans et demi en fait tout est
relatif a réalisé un bel exploit il a
pris le maillot jaune avant n'y est
pourtant de cette 12e étape premiers
assauts des pyrénées on n'attendait pas
de bouleversement vous montrons d'abord
dans l'attention de font romeu battue
est mécontent van impe les autres même
que poulidor galdos baronchelli
bertoglio ocaña pollentier martens lopez
carril cuyper battu mécontents bernard
thévenet est bien évidemment de lille il
faut préciser que tva compagne était
pratique aux adversaires de long de la
journée contenter venaient parce qu'il a
permis à l'un de ses équipiers
d'emporter de s'emparer ce soir du
maillot jaune l'opération de lille avait
été mûrement préparée depuis hier dans
les chambres de repos de barcarès la
tactique des hommes au maillot à damier
a fonctionné parfaitement
il fallait faire exploser le peloton
pour épurer le classement général encore
tout vu ce suspect l'échappée 2 2 lille
des planchers au cours de l'ascension du
deuxième col de la journée
situé à 80 km de l'arrivée devait servir
de catalyseur en fait ce fut l'explosif
de lille a d'abord rattrapé le jet
melendez un espagnol les laissant sur
place et poussant un énorme
développement il n'a jamais été menacé
même lorsque pas l'ipda bergamo et le
jet que nous voyons ici sont venus le
taquiner c'était cinq minutes derrière
dans la montée sur font romeu 20
kilomètres d'ascension beaucoup de monde
le normand a trouvé un terrain idéal
pour laisser s'exprimer totalement sa
classe et son métier énorme travail de
sape qui a porté ses fruits
et même s'il avait voulu changer de
développement de l'île il n'aurait pas
pu une feuille de plastique bloquant le
mécanisme de son dérailleur
pendant les dix derniers kilomètres et
sachant ses adversaires résignées trois
kilomètres plus bas parfaitement
renseignés sur l'écart de lille a tout
bousculé cinq minutes d'avancé au sommet
sur melendez qui l'avait accompagné à un
moment 5 et 2 kg à tort sur panizza dix
minutes trente sur pollentier près de 7
minutes sur hot melt baronchelli
poulidor van ninh cuyper ocaña lopez
carril légal d'eau de l'île après
l'arrivée rabhi on comprend avait même
le temps tranquillement d'enfiler le
maillot jaune et de se rafraîchir
pour un peu il aurait pris sa douche en
attendant l'arrivée de l'adversaire et
vous allez voir que seul un espagnol qui
l'avait accompagné 1
melendez a sauvé la face deuxième à
quatre minutes 50 mais il n'est pas
dangereux au classement général menendez
ce n'est pas grave et un peu plus bas
alors que david était arrivé alors que
mendez avait franchi la ligne dans les
derniers lacets le peloton a sauvé ces
derniers hectomètres avec van impe avec
polydor d'autres mails puis père galdos
lopez carril bertoglio baronchelli ocaña
des thévenet cm qui vous loyers a été
victime d'une chute à 300 mètres de la
ligne
convoqué par un spectateur trop
bandoulière thévenet perd finalement 24
secondes sur les autres prétendants à la
victoire
thévenet ce faire tu as perdu quelques
secondes mais de lille est premier au
classement général devant nîmes bat de
quarante et une autre marque à 2 47
poulidor à 4,6 s galdos à 4,45 et
thévenet à 4,53
c'est l'un d'eux qui doit gagner
aujourd'hui le tour de france
dernier acte demain d'une affaire de
fusion pétrolière qui a mobilisé le
monde politique avant de passionné
l'opinion et pourtant il s'agit d'une
opération d'importance nationale
puisqu'il a fallu l'aval du conseil
d'état au rapprochement entre la société
nationale des pétroles d'aquitaine dont
46% à partir des actionnaires privés et
le groupe era contrôlait en totalité par
les rapprochements souhaités par le
gouvernement c'est donc demain que les
actionnaires des pétroles d'aquitaine
doivent se prononcer définitivement sur
cette fusion qui ferait du nouveau
groupe société nationale l aquitaine une
entreprise tout à fait capable de
concurrencer les grands groupes
pétroliers internationaux
contrôlée à 100% par l'état l'erap règne
aujourd'hui sur le raffinage et possède
de nombreuses filiales de production et
d'exploration d'hydrocarbures en mer du
nord et en mer d'iroise
mais la recherche de l'or noir coûte
cher très cher et les rap dispose d'un
énorme domaine international à
prospecter
d'un côté une snp arish par
l'exploitation du gisement de lacq
de l'autre les rap gourmande de crédit
pour l'exploration
d'où l'idée de fusionner les deux
sociétés pour faire basculer les
disponibilités de la première dans les
caisses de la seconde
de quoi s'agit-il exactement d'une
réorganisation du groupe affirment les
partisans de la fusion qui vise à
rationaliser les structures actuelles du
secteur pétrolier d'état privatisation
répondent les opposants au projet le 9
janvier dernier le ministre des finances
et celui de l'industrie ont accepté
l'opération
julien schwarz député hubert de la
moselle qui a présidé la commission de
contrôle sur les compagnies pétrolières
a réagi le premier avant les socialistes
et les communes
pour lui ce projet devrait être soumise
au parlement car il y a plusieurs entre
deux groupes différents et transferts
d'actifs publics au secteur privé c'est
inexact de dire comme le féminisme de
l'industrie que cette restructuration
s'opère au sein d'un même groupe
or il existe bien deux groupes il existe
les rap et la snpe et j'en ai eu la
confirmation ces jours-ci par une lettre
du ministre de l'économie des finances
qui me dit que l'erap d'une part et la
snpr d'autre part ont bénéficié jusqu'à
présent d'un agrément au régime du
bénéfice consolidé et il ajoute ceci
afin de tenir compte de la spécificité
de chaque entité chef de groupe
il ya donc bien deux groupes il ne
s'agit pas d'un même groupe
des bases juridiques querelles
politiques aussi les députés sont
divisés sur ce problème
même au sein de la majorité pour maurice
herzog chargé de mission parlementaire
auprès du ministre de l'industrie pour
les affaires d'énergie cette fusion est
légal je suis d'un avis opposé à julien
schwartz est d'ailleurs assez titre man
collègue est isolé au sein de la
majorité
la firme paraît très simple et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il y a tellement
de discussions à cet égard il y à une
nécessité absolue c'est de restructurer
l'ensemble de l'erap de faire en sorte
que cette nouvelle société contrôlée
entièrement par l'état
après comme avant est une taille
internationale capable d'être
compétitive avec les grands monstres que
vous connaissez tous en réalité je pense
que le parlement n'a pas à délibérer sur
cette affaire les pétroliers non plus ne
partage pas le point de vue du député de
la moselle
ils ont surnommé le charbonnier ou re la
fusion ne peut être rentable
leur objectif est de constituer un
groupe de dimension internationale
l'asn a société nationale elf aquitaine
aux termes de la fusion l'erap se
transformera en un holding financier en
cerveau du groupe toujours contrôlé à
100% par l'état
elle détiendra alors 70% du capital de
l'asn à 30% resteront entre les mains
d'actionnaires fried
cependant et c'est là que le projet le
plus contesté les races l'utilisera pas
la totalité de sa participation de 70%
dans l'asn eu un élan déposera 18% à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations ou
ces actions seront gelés l'état ayant
l'intention de n'utiliser ses droits de
vote dans la nouvelle société à
concurrence de 50 2%
que deviendront alors les actions gelée
de l'érable c'est bien sûr la question
que se posent les opposants à la fusion
l'homme qui est responsable de toute
cette opération et le pdg des deux
sociétés actuelles elle fera pc npa
pierre guillaumat on le surnomme depuis
20 ans le gars de l'énergie son projet
selon lui est inattaquable absolument
voulu d'être accusée ni de national
as you need des nationalisations les
droits de l'état à travers les rap
restent les mêmes
après qu'avant ils sont simplement
exercé d'une façon différente
on va geler dans cette opération
18 % d'actifs publics et on parle d'une
vente dans un deuxième temps de ses
actions au secteur privé qu'en sera-t-il
exactement nous avons préféré confier
ses 18 % la caisse des dépôts
mais et c'est nous qui allons continuer
à recevoir les dividendes correspondant
à ses 18 % nous avons simplement voulu
que nos actionnaires privés sache que
nous n'exerçons rions pas nous droit de
majorité au delà des quelques 50 4% que
nous possédons actuellement et dans
l'avenir nous pensons nous servir de cet
excès de majorité de l'état dans
l'intérêt de la spa devenu et ses nerfs
en général de façon à pouvoir
ils permettent d'acquérir des
entreprises nouvelles en échangeant des
actions et de ce fait le pourcentage de
l'érable baissera des seniors mais que
deviendra l'erap dans cette opération
qui est pour l'instant un établissement
public l'erap demeure comme un
établissement public et il reste
l'actionnaire majoritaire de la snr mais
le restera-t-elle longtemps naseaux
renner elf aquitaine
qu'est ce que c'est par jour depuis
quelques semaines la publicité d'elf
aquitaine qui officiellement ne vend
rien inquiète les ennemis de la fusion
il y voit une sensibilisation de
l'opinion publique et un appel déguisé
aux actionnaires privés bien sûr l'heure
n'est plus aux grands projets nationaux
comme au moment de la création de
l'érable mais à la rentabilité
l'asn à seraing groupe puissant et
compétitif la présence d'actionnaires
individuels dans ce groupe
or l avantage d'associer les pagnes
privé au financement d'investissements
qui s'annonce considérable à légende
autant la participation de l'état
l'opération de pierre guillaumat a reçu
un accueil favorable du ministre de
l'industrie
car elle s'inscrit parfaitement dans le
droit fil de la politique de libéralisme
avancé qui prévoit de nouvelles
ouvertures vers l'initiative privée
mais ce projet inquiète
le parti socialiste pour lequel la
menace de dénationalisation du secteur
pétrolier est réel il n'y a pas d'échec
des nationalisations juridiquement
aujourd'hui mais tout juridiquement est
prêt pour que la dénationalisation se
fasse éventuellement et c'est notre
inquiétude
nous ajoutons qu'une modification de
cette importance dans la structure du
patrimoine public du patrimoine de
l'état devrait normalement exiger un
vote du parlement
l'actionnaire principal est en l'état où
l assemblée générale c'est le parlement
et nous trouvons que la procédure est à
cet égard plus qu'un correct
nous avons d'ailleurs saisi le premier
ministre d'où le parti socialiste et
nous attendons sa réponse avant de
savoir si un recours contentieux est
possible autre sujet d'inquiétude pour
les socialistes
dans ce projet de fusion l'emploi le
déclin de ce gisement black commencera
en 1983 le personnel craint d'être
condamné mais pour michel d'ornano
le ministre de l'industrie la création
de l'asn à présente un double avantage
celui de sauver le personnel de la snp a
et celui de former un groupe géant du
pétrole qui sera le numéro deux en
france après la compagnie française des
pétroles
la compétition internationale est dur il
ya des sociétés multinationales
étrangères puissante
nous avons besoin d'un groupe simplifiée
et puissant est ce qu'elle est légal
bien sûr naturellement cette affaire
aurait dû passer devant le parlement
s'il y avait eu transfert du secteur
public au secteur privé en réalité il ya
transfert du secteur public au secteur
public
alors bien sûr il y a une part de
capitaux privés qui se trouve dans l'un
de ces groupes à l'heure actuelle mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ces capitaux
privés
est ce que ce sont des grandes sociétés
pas du tout
ce sont des milliers et des milliers de
petits épargnants
alors est-ce qu'il fallait les expulser
nous avons contraire besoin de l'epagne
française
et puis la politique que nous menons
doit être une politique qui protège les
intérêts de l'état mais qui protège
aussi les petits épargnants et nous
entendons les protéger cette opération
est parfaitement légal d'ailleurs elle
est autorisée par un décret pris en
conseil d'état
est ce que cette restructuration est
bonne pour les travailleurs
oui elle l'est elle assure leur
protection dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
et puis vous savez pour les travailleurs
la sécurité de l'emploi et bien c'est
une société capable efficace et
puissante
l'épilogué de cette affaire elf
aquitaine devrait intervenir le 9
juillet les actionnaires privés de la
snp a diront s'ils acceptent ou non la
fusion avec les rats quel que soit le
résultat de leur vote
rarement opération financière aura été
aussi contesté un carts disputée
aujourd'hui à enghien dans la 4e course
il fallait jouer le 15
le 14 las et le sis dans l'ordre pour 1
franc 33540 240 et dans un ordre
différent
toujours pour 1 franc 2795 francs 20 la
météo enfin un peu de fraîcheur
aujourd'hui au très légère si ce matin
un petit vent frais de ces visages après
midi les choses se gâtaient com
peu et ligne par exemple il faisait tout
même 30 degrés demain des orages
violents sur la corse la provence les
alpes le jura ainsi que sur l'est de la
france en soirée mais surtout un peu de
pluie le matin au village de
l'atlantique et ses pluies s'étendront
au bassin parisien où massif central il
y aura du mistral dans la méditerranée
vers les médias allemands la rédaction
d'antenne 2 se joint à moi pour vous
souhaiter une soirée comme vous les
aimez à demain bonsoir
avant de refermer ce journal les
principaux types de l'actualité projet
de loi sur les plus values les sénateurs
finissent les discussions cette nuit
à madrid adolfo suarez choisi un
gouvernement de transition pour attendre
les élections législatives
raymond delisle maillot jaune demain au
départ de la 13e étape
le gouvernement d'accord pour la fusion
entre elf et rap et les pétroles
d'aquitaine
à 23 heures la dernière édition du
journal avec bernard pradines